today we're doing a render challenge but
it's a very very special render
challenge for two reasons one we're
going to be going up against one of the
most successful digital artists in the
entire world people
yeah
playing goddamn monkey balls or
something like legit going to be a total
pilot we've had them here in the studio
before but not since the explosive
growth of crypto r and nfts and all that
fun stuff so what makes this render
challenge extra extra special is that
we're going to take each work of art
that we create and mint them as nfts
that will be going on sale in a charity
auction so in the spirit of people let's
make some mother
dog
renters
can i come in
is okay is it chill if i come in dude
just one exception i've only been gone
for like a day all right fine
so once a year a man comes into our
office and his name is not santa claus
it's mike b
winkleman
it's the beep so beepo is an incredible
artist he's been doing stuff like every
day for 13 years at this point but the
last time he was here who's just that an
incredible artist now he's the world's
premier crypto artist
oh yeah welcome to the new studio by the
way wait was all this here before this
is biggest oh my god
what the hell is everybody working on
what is it
we've decided that today's render
challenge will have the theme of
portrait but what will truly make it a
render challenge is that we'll have to
work in teams of two
names hat go so we're gonna draw names
from a hat we'll get our teams the teams
have a moment to talk about what we're
gonna do wait i thought it is time two
hours yeah it is mother's time as soon
as you pull it out
damn bottle over your head
all right people decree all right all
right all right you gotta throw it on a
physical like flash drive throw it in a
briefcase and the briefcase shuts in two
hours all right you need to go first i
don't want to do it
okay this kid is i don't even know that
it is
i can't wait to see what happens oh my
god i'm gonna draw the next person
yeah yeah all right oh oh no
i'm with clint it's gonna be darkness
the darkness i'm so glad i've heard it
with sam yeah
yes it's gonna be the goofiest crap
right here i promise you according to
people we've started time has started we
gotta go this thing is cooking already
okay this gets trashed wait is this good
we got a two-hour timer that i gotta set
here
and we're off two hours has just started
let's see what these guys can do
obviously if it's a self-portrait i'm
gonna do you know i have a very dark
personality and i know that you as well
clint have a dark personality there's
certainly a dark like well deep inside
what's darker than
the color black
the plan is we're going to split up for
the first half hour we're each going to
do our own thing and then we're going to
reconvene maybe match some assets see
what happens what are you doing vr
i'm i'm pretty slow in 3d programs these
days but i brought my vr headset in my
own laptop which i spent last night
getting set up to be able to sculpt in
vr the idea here is that ren and i can
work together i can like create things i
can give it to him you can build scenes
with it so that's at least our method
that we're going to approach with it'll
be an homage to
all the cool special effects that got us
into making movies wow okay let's get
started
we're this is amazing we've got our game
plan here we are really into dark things
it's gonna basically be like two buff
monks on the outskirts of their chapel
and they're investigating but they're
gonna they're
busting abs and pecs will be visible
i'll i'll do the character pose if you
want to start with like a super cool
environment oh are you doing like an
actual photo scan right now
you don't need to answer them ignore
that i guess do whatever face you want
in your self portrait you could do like
a crazy face a stern face just do it
five four three two
dude you gotta keep the straight face
that was pretty straight dude okay
[ __ ] it went out of focus okay
one more
mike i need you
last chance bro it is what it is this
isn't we don't need ak goddamn robert no
freaking vfx triple a let's go bro two
hours run a gun go
all right that's good enough okay dude
how long does it take to process that
seven minutes totally wasted we are
currently getting some painful face
scans so that we can be part of some
sort of monster kind of like the thing
not used bella's 3d in a little while
and the reason why we're doing bella 3d
instead of photo scanning like peter
because
it's way quicker and it's basically just
as good my goal is to get a black and
white version of my environment sam's
working on the characters the dark now
i'm serious dude it's not even funny how
dark this is gonna be dude yeah keep it
moving we gotta keep moving forward pew
pew pew
[Laughter]
the hell is this kid doing in vr
you got two hours not two freaking years
here guy
because in the metaverse
[Music]
nico that is not appropriate for the
workplace
oh my god busted friggin pervert
got my guy stand here
dude these are just necro
scary monks we'll see how this goes uh i
just realized i'm starting to go into
some territory that i'm very unfamiliar
with which is modeling clothing
basically i'm just building the shell
here let's see if i can do a cloth
stimulation on this got an hour and a
half left
good luck you got a jank ass model of me
in here
i'm gonna send that to mike okay buddy
yeah i'm getting you in here dude that
worked perfect dude that is clutch
this guy crushed it key unit
t unit
[Music]
[Applause]
no you don't want to see you don't oh
dude wait did you freaking students in
this show dude that's freaking sweet
dude wait wait what do we got here buddy
can i have some of these peanuts yeah
help yourself they're a little weird
tasting
not bad
watson eats my damn nose
yo what's up all right so this is kind
of wow that's pretty sweet so it's like
you and me like melted together in this
big flesh thing you know it's all just
sketched right now so right now the
tentacles like kind of come out and then
there you have like the little area for
the heads what i need is for the
tentacles to actually come out more and
then go up into a neck yeah just a
little bit more of that
my computer is frozen
i'm so far ahead on my end i'm gonna
come over and talk to you for some of my
time yeah what's up everybody
everybody what's up well get this out of
here this is a special system what's up
oh that's the simulations you have going
right now for your two-hour render
simulations none dude you have time to
stem out you get a [ __ ] run and gun
bro it's getting in your head i know
wait what is this from oh my gosh what
is this
that's a special edition sam porter
bridges
he wasn't playing around when he said
he's taking the gloves off dude
oh my god is that on purpose he's trying
to get in your head no he's already in
my head i gotta get back in
all right
we got a real rough model i'm gonna give
it here to wren
you wanna try importing it see if it
works
okay it worked
he looks like he's made out of like
clown balloons
okay so now i gotta figure out some sort
of material to put on this this dude
yeah there we go it's starting to get
slimy
[Music]
yes i'm putting teeth in here son
if we're doing creepy mike he's gotta
have some sharp teeth mike i'm just i'm
sorry in advance
what the hell are you doing oh that's
actually pretty freaking sweet so we got
no fat neck
or fat neck mmm fat knack all right yeah
that's sweet like
first crash
but it's cool i save iterations sun okay
buddy where are we at here i'm doing the
eyelids son i'm almost done you're not
gonna see that give me give me give me
give me eyelids
inner butt pupils give me the thing
you're not even gonna see that
dude you didn't do the inner butt pupils
have you finished the inner bucket or is
that sam's responsibility um that's
gonna be on sam yeah the inner butt
people saw for sure no way you're going
to see that detail
all right 10 9 8 7 6 5 4 3 2 1 done
sending sending okay it's sent we have
to combine our crap in 25 minutes or
else take a quick peek
the only thing is like make sure we get
those abs you know like like make sure
the cloak doesn't cover too much you'll
see you'll see his abs for sure the
focal point is the abs i thought it was
your darkness well
the abs pierce the darkness in 25
minutes we'll combine our stuff i'll
drop this in on my computer because i
got the scene ready to go okay cool all
right sweet we're doing it we're really
doing it we're gonna win we're
technically you're not winning because
it's for charity
but it's on the inside
kid's going ape
did he get distracted so yeah i mean the
last thing i i set up the weird mic head
mike's just gonna bring it in
and plop it in his render replace his
head and um
hmm
[Music]
i don't know about this buddy it's hard
to see
it's hard with those i don't like those
eyes can you get rid of those eyes real
quick yes
just make it the one eye i hope we have
time for this dude
how fast do you think you can do that
though five minutes see if you can get
it though but i think it's it's if it's
not as recognizable it's not as strong
you know what i mean
yeah yeah yeah yeah it doesn't need to
be tall
no
crack
dang it okay so it froze again
i don't even i didn't even do anything
this time i got another export going out
for ren
starting to drop some detail in got new
necks in so we can get that laid out and
get placement done
headset battery low
please plug in headset step back and
look at the big picture look at each of
the things that you're doing and be like
okay is this really going to make like a
big difference in the like final product
or is it like pixel [ __ ] tiny detail
that would be nice to have but like
really not that many people are gonna
notice yeah we're going too hard too
hard we went too hard you're breaking my
heart here man it's unrecognizable
sometimes you got no one to backtrack
sometimes you gotta know where to
backtrack you going with regular heads i
think we need to it's very hard to see i
like the idea
but those are the hard things you got to
call when sometimes you get to look at
it and step back and say well what's
going to be best even though i put in
this time
might be best to backtrack we have
20 minutes oh
19 minutes now
ren's got a good scene built here with
some pretty cool lights and a good
material on this creature as long as
there's a blue screen
okay this is full on butt trash dude how
can we make it better maybe he needs a
light on us
maybe a bit more light
the render is looking really nice
guy one guy two
[Laughter]
it's so dark
that's so cool
[Laughter]
i made their eyes glowing
it really feels like a self-portrait
especially when they're like 100 dark
god i wish there was like some abs in
there though hold
i'm gonna go on some gummy bears yeah
dude bring me some gummy bears bro
working with a sweet gummy bear got this
mic
you got this i'm encouraging him with
gummies what kind of gummy bears are
these yeah
i'm sure yeah i'm sure they're
sugar-free we have 10 minutes and we got
a blue screen on our hands
i'm still chill because what's the point
in stressing i think it's just the
mirror we just need the mirror yeah what
is in the mirror so we just go
downstairs where it's totally dark in
one of the dark
rooms we have six minutes here
all right here wait wait wait wait wait
come on this is a selfie
oh yeah yeah
ready
okay cool
dude this is freaking we get gold right
here okay okay it's done nice
we're rendering we're under gonna get a
little color grade and we're good to go
got four minutes four and a half minutes
dude this thing is not your
drive is garbage it's not working
goddamn raiders of the lost ark
boom
okay do the honors buddy all right hell
yeah
there it is okay god damn it do the
honors in this game okay
uh you guys have three minutes left for
dunking
and dunking it in
the color fast
dope [ __ ] oh damn that is sick two and a
half minutes two and a half minutes two
and a half minutes it will be
disqualified it's gotta be in the box we
might not have time
stick in a box
drop it on the drive drop it on the
drive we're good to go we got
we got two minutes left we're good we're
good sorry here we miscommunicated put
them put them back in the mirror at the
hole make a copy of the background the
layer
143 or
whatever they make they get they're
never gonna make it this is fine two
disqualifications this guy knows what
it's about this guy knows you about to
see your teammates get disqualified
demoralized probably won't even come
into work tomorrow
that's not a thumbs drive it's a thumb
drive no it's not it's the using
extension so the what i thought was a
flash drive was just a usb extender
somehow an ivs flash drive her old flash
drive from like 10 years ago on my desk
thanks ivy
i'm not a fan of how that mirror i know
[Music]
rip it rip it rip it rip it first
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
stressful it's always stressful but it
was really fun i'm glad that me and sam
made a necro piece of art brandon and i
i think came up with some really cool
things i'm really excited to see what
peter and mike did i'm really excited to
see what sam and clint did
so in doing a self-portrait we wanted to
capture an image that really uh
had our essence you know our
personalities that came to mind
this is a
[Music]
[Applause]
look at that mirror dude that's a sexy
render right there god damn is that a
kickback 3d cathedral in the background
so wait these are you guys are yes
that's us
we've captured our essence in this
picture okay we're gathering our asses
is this six-pack
son give me a [ __ ] yeah
give me a goddamn break here those abs
are pretty skins of you guys right yes
yeah yeah we 3d scanned ourselves
freaking crash dad dude
i see you in that picture just as much
as i see me 100
i'm excited all right guys tough act to
follow tough activa
give us a chance
so we don't have any special simulations
but we do have a handcrafted monster
oh
okay
oh my god
freaking poop monster over here
goddamn poopoo bladder holy jesus god
this is what you see of yourself ouch
it totally reminds me of the thing
that's what we were going for we were
really inspired by the thing here it's
lit well it's like very sharp and nice
mike should we show ours oh let's do it
buddy
i am only expecting absolute perfection
[Music]
[Applause]
dude
peter what's on your face so he still
has some face tats which i feel like are
imminent for this guy i've always wanted
to face tattoo this is a dream come true
peter i was just curious what you know
once again great work on this thank you
you know all the stuff you put into it i
can tell like really really paid off and
i was wondering if you could maybe uh
give us a quick tour of how you uh
contributed to this
okay
no you're always the
you are easily one of the best visual
effects artists i know and you know and
like looking at this i just feel like it
must be really great to collab with mike
here
you know yeah
so it's a great collab yeah where's
where's the artist touched on your
behalf i think that i'm gonna go ahead
and mirror that question a little
redirect over to mike
we go too hard on this kid or we go do i
don't even know this kid
i mean i did just call him jimmy
no this kid honestly i would not have
come up with these head scan things i
didn't know about that software so
great work peter thanks man yeah
appreciate it you were you were sitting
back playing with toys the whole time
that's because literally probably 20
minutes and i had like
at least something that could be done
yeah and i feel like that takes the
pressure off if you have like a a
minimum viable product like earlier in
the design process then it's really like
well worst case is this yeah and then
you just kind of refine on that and then
you can like step back and look at it
too and like that's another thing is
like literally getting up and like okay
like step back how does it look because
if you can get something that looks good
as like a thumbnail from further away it
will almost definitely look good like
blown up but if it doesn't look good as
a thumbnail probably blown up it almost
definitely will not look good
this is definitely one of the most fun
rendered challenges we've ever done with
people but what makes it so special is
the fact that we have now minted these
as nfts that are available for auction
right now on makersplace.com corridor
digital with people's notoriety that he
has right now this is a big opportunity
for us to do something good for the
world so a hundred percent of all the
proceeds from this auction are going to
go to charities specifically to cover 19
related charities with direct relief
being the main beneficiary so
go out there and bid because we can help
people with this money and
hopefully change some lives if you want
to find out more about what crypto r is
nfts and how all this stuff really works
our last video goes into that really
deep we we sat down with them and talked
about every little detail of what this
new art world entails so go check that
out so this whole nft crypto art space
is fascinating we're going to be doing
more explorations of this as well if you
miss out on this auction don't sweat it
we'll be we'll be doing more things down
the line but right now let's raise some
money for charity all right
makerspace.com corridor digital links in
the description below let's go help some
people
so
[Music]
you